gretchen whitmer now facing illegal
backlash over new coveted restrictions
she ordered a ban on indoor dining that
took effect wednesday after a surge of
new coronavirus cases in the state
but a trade group is now suing to try
and stop it saying restaurants quoting
here
have lost the ability to use their real
and personal property in any meaningful
economically beneficial manner
plaintiffs have no adequate remedy at
law for this continuing violation
of their constitutional rights the
president of the michigan restaurant and
lodging association justin winslow joins
us now justin
thank you for coming on we appreciate it
in the suit
what are you hoping for you want 50
capacity back in the restaurants 25
what would you settle for that's exactly
right we would love the opportunity to
get back to doing what we know how to do
which is safely serve guests
and keep our employees safe at the same
time and i think the data in michigan
suggests as much
so we're hoping the suit will put a
quick pause and allow restaurants to
get back to doing what they do best yeah
i want to play this quick
sound bite from the michigan governor
and get your response on the other side
the situation has never been more dire
we are at the precipice and we need to
take some action
you know justin she's right i mean look
the situation clearly across the country
is getting worse
but you know what i find interesting
about this is restaurants are always the
low hanging fruit right
restaurants and bars and gyms low
hanging fruit and they're the first ones
that are shut down
and i pulled up this study this is from
public health england
kind of the british equivalent of the
cdc and they
say the number one place in their
contact racing that people report going
is the supermarket
and all the way down at 16 one percent
of people
reported before they got the virus going
to a restaurant or cafe
and yet nobody's talking about shutting
supermarkets and everybody talks about
shutting down the restaurants
what do you think about that yeah listen
i think you're right the numbers don't
look great in michigan right now and the
hospitalizations have increased as well
i think the restaurant industry has
become a convenient scapegoat
and we have tried very hard to
demonstrate how
how much we put safety at the forefront
of everything we do every single day
and it shows up in those numbers exactly
as you referenced the numbers in
michigan and they are
the contact tracing data occurs is
presented
and it shows minimal transmission from
this industry
in fact much lower than many industries
that remain open for business right now
so
we can't help but wonder why we are
singled out yet again after being shut
down for
85 days in a row earlier this year yeah
and the wall street journal kind of
echoed that
running a story this week they pulled up
all the numbers showing that you know
really more than
50 percent up to 75 percent of the
infections
we just don't know where people are
getting infected so to point
at different industries and schools and
so forth is really disingenuous because
the truth is science matters and we
really don't know
i want you to pull up this is part of
the lawsuit quoting here on the layoffs
you say more than 40 percent of
restaurants are now likely to close
at least temporarily these are numbers
from the michigan department of health
and human
services at least temporarily and 250
000
employees are likely to be laid off from
restaurants over the holiday season
big financial hit to your industry as we
move toward the holidays
yeah that's exactly right and we don't
talk about this as the human toll 250
000 people laid off over the holidays
and we do not we do not have
uh the safety net that was in place
earlier in the spring when there were
some kaizak dollars
to soften the blow the blow will be
tremendous we think six thousand more
restaurants are going to close in the
coming months
because of this closure and 250 000
maybe 300 000 employees
will lose their jobs and i don't know if
they have any of the benefits to help
see them through this
yeah i've been reading these articles on
restaurants across the country and how
they've had these robust kind of uh
retaliatory plans this to-go meals
they're they're serving and even just
giving the the food to make these meals
have you found
anything that can that can at least you
know
try and tide some of these businesses
over until
um maybe you know you get 25 50
capacity back what's the thought there
yeah this is a the restaurant industry
is very resilient and it is very
creative and has found a lot of ways to
help itself survive
but i think a lot of restaurants learned
from the spring what worked and what
didn't work
and so when you hear that 40 number that
means 40 restaurants know
that carryout or delivery isn't going to
get it done for them and they can't
afford to lose more money over the
coming weeks maybe months
so they're just going to stay closed and
lastly people don't realize in a look in
california it's easy to have outside
dining for much of the year in michigan
not so easy and it really you know it's
it's devastating for a lot of people
in the restaurant industry that's right
that's exactly right winter's going to
be tough around here in michigan
yeah well justin winslow great of you to
come on best of luck to you and your
industry thank you
thank you for the time